as presents are being unwrapped from
under the Christmas trees the French
government has given its citizens a gift
that they may want to return it's passed
a new law to increase taxes on SUVs and
trucks meaning that vehicles that
pollute the most will pay more from 2020
the new pollution tax will come with a
twenty thousand euro price tag that's up
from the current twelve and a half
thousand euros it's no doubt that SUVs
are heavy polluters but despite that
they are still popular in France making
up some 30% of sales in the first 11
months of 2019 so what do drivers in
Paris make of the tax hike really it's
true that those vehicles consume a lot
but people have to get around people
work everyday and they need those types
of vehicles for work it's pity there's
no other way to earn money
everything's increasing in price
nowadays and we've seen the whole
country on strike it's unfair in France
you have to pay and pay and pay taxes
are rising well salaries are staying the
same the new tax comes on top of already
tough new measures at a European level
to lower car emissions many governments
are pushing people in the direction of
buying electric cars which are seen as
being greener and better for the
environment but at the same time the
French government is actually
considering reducing cash incentives for
new electric cars
perhaps not great news for those who are
thinking of buying one France also plans
to ban fossil fuel cars within the next
20 years in Paris they could be banned
in the next 10 years so do people here
feel that they are being pushed by
higher taxes on vehicles that use
traditional fuel towards electric cars
it's a natural progression that we're
seeing one which will lead to more and
more electric cars electric cars why not
if they're good we can use them in our
country if the government helps us to
buy electric cars why not but otherwise
it referred to
even if it's not that bad and there are
other concerns whilst many people say
they want to be greener charging points
for electric vehicles are still not
widespread whilst here in Paris there
are plenty around the city elsewhere
that's not always the case we need to
have enough places to recharge them in
addition to service centers it's the
same as with cycle lanes in German we're
a long way behind we have to develop
cycle lanes and we have to develop
charging stations actually vehicles in
front seem to be developed that's not
even the president doesn't set a good
example travels by car while we travel
by food by bicycle by scooter so it
seems there are still many mental
barriers for people even thinking about
buying electric cars but as the cost of
taxes on fossil fuel vehicles are set to
steeply rise they may feel that there is
no other choice
you